in 2007 we tried comprehensive
immigration reform I along with Senator
Kennedy McCain Kyle senator men did
Mendez and others put together a
comprehensive bill that focused on
border security a temporary worker
program so our employers could access
labor from overseas in a win-win fashion
we had an employer verification system
making it harder to hire illegal
immigrants and we did what I thought a
rational thing with the 12 million
illegal immigrants would allow them to
raise their hands identify themselves
and if they committed no crime other
than breaking our immigration laws they
were given a legal status and they could
earn their way to citizenship only after
getting behind those who are doing it
right so to come out of the shadows you
would be a biometrical identified you'd
be required to learn our language pay a
fine for the crime you committed get in
the back of the line to become a citizen
and it would take from 8 to 13 years in
that process to get to citizenship if
that was your goal so I think that is a
workable solution that needs to be
refined what's happened from 2007 to now
is the border is less secure in the
violence in Mexico is getting out of
control so you have to look at 2010-2011
immigration politics through the Arizona
eyes the the people in Arizona feel
under siege they pass a statute that's
controversial but other states are
taking up similar statutes so the tide
is turned where the American people are
focusing on securing our borders which i
think is a good thing but I think most
Americans 221 still believe that you
have to be rational logical when it
comes to the 12 million on our southern
border life is not so good if I lived in
a southern hemisphere nation that had no
hopes i'd be enticed to come to America
and that quite frankly we're going to
need immigrants we're a declining
population as I said before Japan has
been very xenophobic they don't have a
workforce we're going to need immigrants
as far as the eye can see I just want
them to become legal and do it in a
win-win way